[Musique]
bienvenue dans la fraîcheur printanière
de saint-etienne la sélection de la
réunion de cécifoot va représenter notre
île en métropole au tournoi andy
supporters à saint-etienne heureux
d'être en métropole cette équipe est
composée de dix joueurs porteurs de
handicap et de trois accompagnateurs
dont fait partie david hoareau manager
sportif de l'association cécifoot tafer
la quatrième année que nous met ce
projet-là en place c'est important parce
que ce sont des jeunes qui sont éloignés
de la pratique sportive des bêtes à ces
jeunes de de faire du sport de refaire
du sport d'être valorisés en fait sur la
pratique donc développé aussi une estime
de soi l'idée c'est ça les objectifs
sont affichés changer le regard des
jeunes envers eux-mêmes mais aussi les
considéré avant tout comme des sportifs
à part entière montrer qu'ils sont
autrement capables
ce tournoi est donc un excellent moyen
d'exposer leur talent mais aussi de
faire tomber les barrières et permettent
à moins de trouver tenter
et d'autres personnes et morabity
omourbek et auront pour des pelles
équipées de deux pays je trouve que
c'est bon parce que c'est un échange
normal habitué à tout le monde c'est le
partage
on est libre et fière un beau projet qui
nécessite une logistique soutenu par des
partenaires financiers
ce sont des initiatives accompagné par
le département de la réunion qui est
sensible aux actions d'intégration
sociale ce séjour à caractère sportif et
culturel été réalisés par notre
association pour à paunat le département
de la réunion qui accompagne sur deux
sur ce projet par intermedia de madame
dindar et ensuite on a aussi un ths
territoires ruraux jeunesse et sport qui
nous accompagnent en fait sur ce projet
qui permet en fait de nous accueillir à
saint-etienne et l'association des
réunionnais de 5 mrd soutien essentiel
pour ces associations qui peuvent plus
facilement accompagner aider leurs
jeunes porteurs de handicap à trouver
une place dans la société
et c'est avec fierté qu'ils
représenteront la réunion lors de ce
week end sportif sur les terrain
stéphanois
[Musique]